qui es-tu
Ethan mon travail consiste à chasser les terroristes
dans les trois jours je le trouve
aiza trois jours à tuer parle d'un homme
qui accepte ce qui compte le plus
dans sa vie bon ou mauvais quand tu travailles
pour l'agence ça devient ton tout
vie Ethan est décidément américain vivant
à Paris ce personnage est assez proche
de moi je me suis beaucoup lié à lui c'est
quelqu'un qui a passé trop de temps au
travail tu es le meilleur agent nous avons besoin de toi je
ne veux pas passer le reste de mon temps  la vie
se libère il a perdu le contact avec ce qui
compte le plus dans la vie il revient de
nulle part nous ne l'avons pas vu depuis des années alors
tu veux que je t'appelle papa ou devrais-je
juste t'appeler Ethan a eu comme ça nous
venons de retirer cracher un peu plus  temps
que ma fille les idées standard d'
essayer de prendre soin de votre ménage
un peu un mystère pour lui il y a trois
femmes avec lesquelles il doit négocier au
fur et à mesure qu'il avance dans cette
histoire j'ai besoin de vous pour un dernier travail je
ne suis pas  dans le business plus ambre elle il
joue  le filtre top roll laisse une
Américaine qui s'épanche à Paris
elle répond à ses propres besoins et désirs
tu ne devrais
pas être cinq oups l'élément le plus
excitant de tout le film est hailee
steinfeld mon personnage Zoey vit à
Paris avec sa mère c'est une toute
autre histoire  monde Zoey je vais faire le
dîner ce soir si je veux faire de
la sauce à spaghetti prête à aider il
se trouve que je suis en réunion ici avec le
vrai italien en direct qu'il veut vous donner
est une excellente recette pourquoi ne dites-vous pas
bonjour  à ma fille je sais que je suis un Guido
je sais que je n'ai pas bien agi avec toi profite de
Connie Nielsen Browns le film en
jouant l'ex-femme Christine pour que je
lui fasse à nouveau confiance il doit me promettre
qu'il ne travaillera pas pour  la CIA
que j'aurais dû quitter il y a longtemps
c'est un idiot très complet ce n'est pas
qu'une
chose c'était une joie de travailler avec tout le monde
c'est pourquoi le cinéma est si excitant
beaucoup de mes amis les pères sont dans les ventes et
pas l'une des robes comme  toi je
vais avoir besoin d'un nouveau  combinaison